[Music]
individual artistic vision was something
that distinguished the 80s and why we
suddenly got these films unlike anything
that we've seen before coming out of
china hello and welcome to chinese
whispers with me cindy yoo every episode
i'll be talking to journalists experts
and long-time china watchers about the
latest in chinese politics society and
more
there will be a smattering of history to
catch you up on the background knowledge
and some context how do the chinese see
these issues you probably wouldn't
expect to see the cultural revolution on
the chinese big screen or the great leap
forward or the tiaman square protests
but for a certain subsection of the
chinese films industry for a certain
generation of directors these were
common themes at least for time they
weren't always welcomed by the sensors
but they weren't always banned either
this is what i wrote about for a recent
column for the spectator where i look at
the golden age of chinese cinema just
after the cultural revolution
and what has happened to this to the
industry now you'd be surprised and
amazed at the incredible subversiveness
both political and social from directors
like chiang kai-ga and jung-yum
unfortunately these days it's films like
wolf warrior 2 that dominate the box
office so what's happened to the
industry
i'm joined on this episode by professor
chris berry who is a professor of film
studies at king's college london
chris thank you so much for joining
chinese whispers um to start with can we
talk about the fifth generation
directors that golden age i just
mentioned but in order to do so could
you first set the scene of what the film
industry was like uh during the cultural
revolution presumably it was quite a
stifling time
i think it was a very special time um
actually the cultural revolution
although it was very strictly under
political control the film industry was
also under pressure to produce very
radical forms of art so the model operas
for example zhang ching's model operas
which were a sort of mix of
ballet
chinese opera
and sort of revolutionary culture
were being produced as very original art
forms but they were not forms that were
the vision of individual artists if you
like it was the art of the state
in this high radical period in the 60s
the film industry itself was
100 state-owned and controlled and it
operated on a command economy model
which means that the funding
came from the government down to the
film studios
there were annual meetings of the head
of the film studios all of them stayed
owned and operated and they were
essentially given a plan
this year you're going to make four
films that are on our agricultural
policy you're going to make five films
that will illustrate what we're
concerned about with youth at the moment
and so on so it was not a model of
film as art or a film as commerce either
and that's really what began to change
in the 80s
with the fifth generation that's amazing
i would of course chanting you mentioned
this chairman mao's wife at the time and
one of the gang of four and she was an
actress of course i had forgotten about
that she was an actress with the amazing
name of blue apple
in the 1930s
and so she considered herself to be
an expert on film and in many ways she
was
so she really did pay a lot of attention
to the film industry
and she was obsessed with things like
the quality of the color in films very
technical things and not just very
political things there are these
notorious stories of her requiring that
films be re-shot again and again until
they achieve the technical standard that
she wanted
and i'm not sure if you know this but
it's because of her
that and this this concern with certain
quality reds blues etc etc and greens in
particular she was very concerned about
greed
that they imported technicolor the last
functioning technicolor plant was
imported from the united kingdom to
china
and so in the late 70s actually
eventually but she was the one who
initiated that because they wanted that
quality that only technicolor could give
them so i guess
as with the soviets in russia film and
popular culture in general was seen as a
way of propagandizing getting your
message across a revolutionary message
but
at the end of the cultural revolution
when the beijing film academy resumed
classes and started taking students
again
a new generation of directors came and a
side note is that we call these
directors the fifth generation directors
but actually the labeling of generations
at all started with the fifth generation
because they were so seen as so great
and then from the fifth generation
people started backdating the previous
four and what came after them as well so
what exactly made these directors so
groundbreaking so special i think the
really crucial thing was in fact the
education they received at the beijing
film academy in the late 1970s
the teachers at the beijing film academy
were really interested in what had been
going on all those years when everything
was closed up during the cultural
revolution
and so with the assistance of
embassy collections of films and things
like that they were showing their
students italian neo-realist films
french new wave
all of which was unknown you know there
had been 10 15 years in which china had
been essentially closed off to the
outside world
except for albania and north korea
and so
this was a very exciting moment when
suddenly the idea of film as an
individual artist's vision the idea of
art film which had already been very
well established in europe for the last
20 years and not just in western europe
also in eastern europe that came into
china really in the 70s late 70s early
80s
and so this was a generation of
filmmakers
who saw filmmaking as about the
expression of their own vision
in a way that previous generations just
didn't
if they'd been in republican china it's
much more likely they saw themselves as
making commercial vehicles
if they were post-revolutionary
filmmakers they saw their job as to
convey the state's message as you said
so that idea of individual
artistic vision was something that
distinguished the fifth generation in
the 80s and why we suddenly got these
films that were completely
unlike anything that we've seen before
coming out of china i've thoroughly
enjoyed quite a lot of them during
lockdown um can you talk a little bit
about the themes that they explore in
their films what if anything
characterizes the the common themes that
come up i think the most
frequent theme that comes through
often indirectly because it had to be
expressed indirectly
is the shock that they experienced as
young people during the cultural
revolution
when they were sent down to the
countryside or to remote areas of china
and they discovered that the very glossy
revolutionary image that they'd been
given as children in beijing or shanghai
wasn't what they found in the
countryside they found abject poverty
they found exploitation that was not
supposed to exist under socialism and a
huge
gap between the educated people in the
cities and the very uneducated people in
the countryside
and that comes through
in a film like yellow earth which is
supposedly set in the pre-revolutionary
era with those kinds of experiences
but it's actually obviously about what
they went through in the 60s and 70s
or films
like blue kite
which tells historical stories about
these huge uh generation gaps and huge
issues of uh
people struggling in the in the face of
enormous poverty and uh enormous
challenges and presumably it would have
been the first time that some of these
shocking episodes in chinese recent
history were ever portrayed on the
silver screen in china and outside of
china you know we had a great leap
forward the cultural revolution
um the civil war itself the shooting of
landowners all of these were stories
that they told absolutely and these were
stories that previously either would you
know not acknowledged the existence of
the famine in the late 50s early 60s is
something that even now is very
difficult to speak about
but in the late 70s and early 80s in the
aftermath of the cultural revolution
the party admitted that there had been
errors
and this opened up the possibility for
as i say directly or indirectly uh
talking about that in films um so blue
kite for example is a multi-generation
story which goes through
from the point of view of a little boy
watching
his mother
first of all his father being taken away
but then the other men that she
forms relationships being destroyed one
by one by political campaigns
by various kinds of disasters
that happened after the revolution or
jungimo's film to live which goes from
before the revolution right up to the
cultural revolution in theory
1949 is supposed to mark an absolute
break between the bad old days and the
wonderful new society
but in to live we just see one challenge
one
nightmare for the family after another
up to the cultural revolution
yeah it was amazing i never knew that
chinese film could be so politically
subversive especially in these as i've
already mentioned you know the chinese
speak of the fifth generation so they
are popular in china as well and that's
something we can talk about in a little
bit as well just how popular they were
but the fact that this kind of stuff
could even be a
semi-above board and of course some of
them were censored um
it was just incredible that
this kind of chinese collective memory
because so often i think we hear about
oh the chinese have forgotten about
tiananmen square the chinese have
forgotten about the cultural revolution
and in their films we can see that these
are people working through that kind of
trauma and they haven't forgotten
anything i think
there's it's very important to
acknowledge that that was then but more
recently it's become much more difficult
yeah hold that thought chris because we
will get there we will get there because
ultimately this episode is not super
cheering i think for the film industry
but just i just want to pick up on one
thing that you said that talking about
the shock that these directors felt
themselves i really felt that come
through for example you farewell my
concubine where chiang kaiga the
director um had a very brutal portrayal
of the cultural revolution one scene of
a denouncement um that happened there
and later i found out that he would
actually he was actually a red guard
who had denounced his own father so am i
overreading it to think that in that
scene the brutality of it was him
chastising himself and an apology to his
father really i think so absolutely and
i think um that's what makes that film
so powerful is that you
you feel this resonance this this horror
about what happened and
the regret yes yeah
let's talk about censorship then because
it's not as if the communist party was
happy with a lot of this stuff can you
talk a little bit about what the process
of censorship was like at that stage
because the state had not was no longer
really directing filmmaking but there
was still a lot of censorship so what
did a director like chen kaiger at that
period have to deal with okay so you're
right that the state was no longer
coming in with its annual plans in the
way that it used to
and that system of moving away from that
towards one where
it's more market driven where people
come up with their own ideas for films
uh they seek investment all the things
that we're used to that's how things
have changed in china it has become much
more like a
an industry that people in the market
economy would recognize but the big
difference is that you are supposed to
submit your script to the film bureau
before you start filming
and then you're supposed to show the
film afterwards to them before you can
release it into the movie theaters the
evolution of censorship in china
has gone through various stages and it's
been a bit back and forth but
in the time when chiang kai go and jungi
were making
their films and teen drunk drunk their
famous fifth generation films in the 80s
and 90s
it's not necessarily always the case
that the script had to be submitted
so sometimes they could make the film
and then deal with the sensors
um but now
always the script has to be approved
first
the producers these days prefer that
because
of course it means that they're not so
exposed to economic shock you know in
theory they've got an agreed script and
once they make it they should be able to
release it
um but that then of course
has a an effect on how daring filmmakers
are willing to be
um how daring producers are willing to
be at the moment yeah well i was
speaking to one producer of um an
underground film made much later than
the period we're currently talking about
this film was released in the early
noughties and when i say underground i
mean that has never been shown on the
big screen in china because it was
it never received that kind of approval
from census and this producer was saying
to me that actually
insidiously a lot of senses these days
actually just ask for a plan from you
and then they'll say go back and have
another look at the plan without really
telling you what the problem is whereas
with a script they can mark out a scene
or paragraph or whatever it is that
that's the problem you can excise it or
rewrite it but what the current mode of
vagueness does is self-censorship i
don't know if you've come across that
yeah i think that's absolutely
true in a system where
you either
first of all there's no rating system
there's no classification
yeah so any film that is released in
china can be seen by a five-year-old
child in theory
therefore you know that
gives a certain license to the census to
be demanding many more changes or you
know saying certain things are
inappropriate
um
there is a now a published kind of list
of what's not allowed
but um
those the terms that are used are quite
vague
um so you know you're never quite sure
how to interpret that right it's not
like hollywood where in the 40s and 30s
you were told well there must always be
a foot on the ground if you're in bed
you can't have people having sex et
cetera et cetera so it's very specific
right whereas now in china it's still
quite abstract and that leaves a lot of
room for the censors
um
and i think yes for because it's a
commercial industry now
and so in the 80s maybe as a filmmaker
you didn't feel so responsible for
profits and losses but now you're
dealing with somebody's money so you
can't take so many risks is that just
because the film industry has become
quite so big or it's huge but it's also
commercial it's a profit and loss driven
industry in the 80s that was still in
transition
so the money was still coming from the
state
it wasn't you know you didn't
necessarily have to worry that you were
your film might be seen as a great film
but didn't make a whole heap of money
didn't matter
now it matters a lot because it's
private investment and it's a
market-driven system
and just
seeing as you met you mentioned sex
because it wasn't just politics that got
films into trouble yeah absolutely yeah
it was also how you treat sex but partly
because of this age uh thing you're
mentioning but also heteronormativity
you know the dealing of queer themes gay
themes transgender themes that's also
difficult right but that those did
happen in those films from the from the
fifth generation as well yeah although
you know in the case of farewell my
concubine um
chunker famously at a press conference
denied that it was a gay movie right
which i probably didn't help him any
but you know he obviously
was not seeing it in that way
do you think he meant that yeah i think
i think so i think in the 1990s at that
time in china first
most straight people they probably
didn't see a lot of the things
that a queer viewer would see and
perceive well just just briefly to catch
listeners up in case anyone hasn't seen
farewell my concubine it's the story of
two beijing opera singers uh from you
know the 1930s before the communists
take over who join his troop as boys one
always portrays a concubine a female
character in pharaoh concubine which is
a historic uh beijing opera and the
other always
the king so there is this kind of
exploration of their relationship across
the years and this question over whether
or not the man portraying a woman was in
romantic love with his partner and
possibly even identified
some as some kind of non-binary um
person in his real life but there are i
mean i i just just go back to that
previous question about chenkaiger you
know i can see as an audience how you
might not see that kind of gay undertone
but as the creator of it how could you
possibly create something like that
without thinking that's what you were
doing because there are explicit scenes
in there where the male or older patrons
patronizing the the young actor who's a
woman on stage
you know she he seems very jealous when
his partner goes and get married married
these are not massive spoilers guys so i
don't i don't feel too bad but you know
as a creator surely you had that in mind
yeah but i think for chiang kai-goo he
saw this as
a story about
um
really about chinese history
and about how
the kind of social
structures but also historical events
had psychological impacts on people
and how he thought it was a close
relationship between two men certainly
but i don't think he necessarily wanted
to see it as
a queer film
whereas i think for all the reasons
you've just said
queer audiences see it very much as that
and so for people outside the people's
republic at that time it was very
shocking to hear him say that because it
just seemed so obvious
but inside the prc maybe less so at that
time but today i think you've got a very
different situation where
especially among young chinese people
everybody knows what homosexuality is
i don't think they did in the 1990s yeah
i can tell you categorically that in the
1980s when i was living in china most
people had no idea what homosexuality
was or that it existed
um
yeah they didn't understand it at all so
ten years later i think that was still
just beginning yeah well i mean that's
why off all of the films that we're
mentioning today i think february
concubine is my favorite because it's
not when i watched it i felt it wasn't
only politically subversive it was also
socially subversive um homosexuality
wasn't declassified as a mental illness
in china until 2001. so for 1993 film to
be tackling that but you know
maybe chunkier just accidentally did
um
can we talk about um international
reception then seen as you mentioned
people outside the prc um because these
films part of the reason they achieved
the success they did was because of the
international film festivals they were
well received at cannes they were well
received at tokyo berlin all of these
places is that because they cater more
to western taste i don't think that they
were deliberately catering to western
taste most of these filmmakers have
never spent any time outside china they
wouldn't know how to cater to western
taste even if they tried
but i do think that what happened was of
course as i mentioned they had been
educated
in
with awareness of art film right so art
film is what film festivals are looking
for and they're always looking for
something new
some a country that they didn't know was
making film art films before or a new
you know a new round of cinema so it was
a sort of discovery moment for cannes or
berlin that oh here's something you know
fresh something fresh and so it worked
in that way on the on the festival
circuit
but it doesn't mean these films were big
hits with general audiences in the west
or in china i mean they're very much art
films well i wonder if you can talk a
little bit about the reception in china
actually did your average person like
them no
no well well i mean it there is some
variation okay
so some films like red sorghum johnny
moe's films were big hits okay but jung
emo is in a way the exception that
proves the rule
most of the fifth generation filmmakers
were making films that appealed to
the kind of people who go to see
independent film here as well
so a relatively small percentage they
weren't big box office films yeah but
changi mo was who made red sorghum who
made curse of golden flower to live et
cetera et cetera people might know him a
hero a bit later yeah so these are the
he was the big crossover filmmaker whose
films really did get to a big audience
there were a couple of others but most
of them were um
going to us relatively
educated
urban
elite audience and you have to remember
at this time i mean today half of
china's population more than half of
china's population lives in the cities
but at this time probably
20 percent living in the city the cinema
going wasn't really uh it was big but it
was not but this kind of cinema going
fifth generation cinema was an urban
thing an elite thing so when i
introduced earlier if the fifth
generation has been venerated you know
the whole label of it is that very much
in intellectual circles is that where
the label comes from rather than from
popular appeal yes i think um i wonder
if
today i wonder if ordinary audiences
really what they associate with that or
whether they even know that term
the whole generation thing has sort of
gone now we had a sixth generation that
graduated from the beijing film academy
in 1989
but um after that you have numerous
different film schools opening up in
china and there are many possibilities
for film education so that demarcation
of a class that
enters and then graduates and another
class entering and graduating
that has gone now presumably that
popular appeal is not helped by the fact
that a lot of these films were banned
when they first came out sure i mean
difficult to see them difficult to get
hold of them of course banning a film
can make it high profile and make people
want to see it
um so sometimes in some ways that may
have helped uh build an audience for it
winning awards overseas got local
audiences interested but quite often
then when they went to see the films
because they were so different from what
they were used to they were a bit
baffled by them
so yellow earth would be a good example
of the film that
you know because it doesn't have a
straightforward plot or a narrative line
or a message and it's quite slow
and very visual
without a lot of dialogue i think local
audiences at the time
most of them were quite they didn't
understand why is this film being
you know received with such excitement
at the film festivals but it's precisely
those all those things i just mentioned
are what made it interesting to film
festival audiences because it wasn't
another boy loves tractor film you know
they were getting from china before yeah
yeah do you think with themes that are
difficult um
especially on these political things so
yellow earth being chiang kai one of
chenkaiger's early films about
this really breathtaking poverty that um
northwestern china went through in the
late 1930s um and the feudalism and the
backwoodsness
this very young girl being married off
in child marriage
i've had family members reflect to me
that actually they don't want to see
things like that about china that
actually um i think this person said to
me this is something that does cater to
the western taste because they want to
see china as poverty ridden they want to
see china's backwards
um and for listeners at home chris is
rolling his eyes which is my absolutely
my reaction to that um comment as well
but you know do you think there is this
kind of
back in the 80s or even now audience is
thinking i don't want to talk about
these difficult things these traumas in
our history actually i think it's
important to say about yellow earth that
the chinese audience was used to
numerous films
about how bad things were in the old
society before 1949.
chinese audiences were born and bred and
brought up on a diet of films about how
horrible the old society was
what was
breathtaking about yellow earth
was i think for
intellectual audiences for educated
audience they realized
although it's set in the late 1930s it's
about the experience that those
filmmakers had
in the 1960s in the cultural revolution
when they
like the soldier in the film went down
into the countryside
[Music]
and the only reason that film could pass
censorship
was because it would be
unthinkable for the censors
to accept to admit that they could
imagine that film was actually about the
current situation right
to just to say oh yeah we understood
that's a metaphor for what's going on
now would be completely traitorous right
it would be
unforgivable so the sensors had to if
they if they saw it at all they had to
pretend they didn't yeah that makes
sense and i guess
you know this portrayal suffering in
chinese propaganda always
comes with a happy ending at the end
which this but not in yellow earth yes
exactly the film was very much about
trying to make people think about
you know what happened in the cultural
revolution how did it all go wrong
and to start opening up questions about
how successful has the revolution been
you know what do we need to so it was
very much not
directed at foreigners but directed
internally in china i think
to chinese audiences
to try to make them think about
you know what's going on in china now
yeah
and can we um talk a little bit about
the the the outcomes for censorship you
know what does it mean to be censored uh
were directors punished because some of
these directors then went on to keep
making loads of films so how i guess
dangerous is it to be a band director or
to be a census director
depends on what period you're talking
about
um today i think it's very dangerous
because it means you become
somebody who
is you cannot invest in their work
um so
if a producer puts a whole load of money
into a director's films
um the film
script passes
at the census but then the final film
gets banned the producer loses all that
money
so within a market driven system that's
a huge problem
back in the 80s or 90s
[Music]
filmmakers themselves were not banned
their films were
um but filmmakers themselves were able
to try and go on to make another film
usually
and the process itself presumably is
grueling because you sometimes it can
take years to contact for a script to go
back and forth and i think
i think the
the system is it's not necessarily
grueling but it is frustrating because
you have to you know you have to deal
with people asking what seemed to you as
a filmmaker maybe to be stupid questions
and making demands that are very
difficult and so on especially if you
think you're an artist exactly
exactly yes yes who have not sensitive
to what you're doing
but to give you an example um pemet
sedan is the world's first
consistently working tibetan filmmaker
he came through the beijing film academy
as you know everything about tibet is
incredibly politically sensitive in
china
all of his films are films that are not
simply sending out the party message
but
you know
so you can he himself says every film i
make i have to spend a lot of time in
the film bureau
you know talking my way through all
these scenes making adjustments and so
on
to what to make sure they are acceptable
so it is a process of negotiation i
would say more than anything else you
don't get slammed in jail for making a
film that is in trouble with the sensors
one producer told me that the reason
they never sent their film to um the
film bureau is because they knew that it
would be watered down there was just no
point didn't want to rather because it
can be released on dvd right if it's not
shown on the silver screen it's okay to
be circulated no not necessarily okay um
so since you've mentioned this a couple
of times we have to say something about
this
in china since the development of the
market system
there's been the growth not only of the
commercial industry but also so-called
independent cinema and independent in
china is a bit different from what it
means here we talk when we talk about
independent in the west we usually mean
not mainstream or not big studios
in china it has meant not sent to the
film bureau
if your film does not go through the
film bureau as you said you can't
release it commercially in the movie
theaters
but the film bureau's censorship is only
about the movie theaters
there's another
censorship body that deals with
releasing a dvd
so for some films you're right you could
not maybe not pass
the film bureau but pass the dvd release
but mostly actually if you're making an
independent movie it doesn't get
released anywhere commercially in china
because none of these bodies will pass
i see the film
but
for many years until 2017 when they
passed a new film law
there was the existence of this um
shadow industry if you like that on very
low budgets was making
many documentary films and probably
dozens of feature films every year
they were often going overseas they were
getting into film festivals
so they were seen in china by audiences
in an underground manner as you
suggested
and then they would make some small
amount of money by being sold to
television stations to distributors in
france to in japan in hong kong and so
on and that would create enough of an
income of a revenue stream for them to
survive and make the kinds of films they
wanted to make
although they were not being
shown commercially in china
and chris do you think censorship has
got worse um since the fifth generation
were prop you know properly active or
first active because we've talked about
commercialization becoming worse but has
censorship become tighter
i don't know that censorship has
actually become tighter but i think what
it's the combination of
commercial
factors concerned for not having a film
banned and losing all the money
and censorship together have created a
kind of chilling effect
and the
range of things that people don't want
to touch is getting bigger and bigger as
they
try to avoid that situation i would say
at the moment what's interesting is that
you know the directors like johnny mulch
and kaiger they're still active johnny
moore was directing olympic opening
ceremonies and chiang kai-ga had a major
blockbuster out last year why don't
these directors touch the themes of
their youth anymore i think they've
become much more mainstream they've
become successful individuals in china
they've become co-opted if you like by
the regime and by the system
i think it's younger people who want to
deal with those more difficult themes
and in some cases they are able to get
the story through and get the thing
through censorship
so china's had its first film
called the rib i believe which is the
first trans film about transgenderism in
china
with a transgender actor and so on and
things like that are going on and are
happening but then at the same time you
get quite conservative regulations
saying
no depictions of any homosexuality in
chinese film on television or on the
internet even though it's no longer
regarded as mental illness so you get
you know quite strange um
changes in regulation around these
things yeah because i mean you know you
mentioned earlier that we don't talk
about any generations after the sixth
it's part of the reason that chinese
film has just declined in quality there
is no
you know
i think chinese film has transformed so
i don't think it's declined in quality i
think what's happening
is the chinese film industry is now
massive
um i'm not sure if you're aware but the
chinese box office is now the biggest
box office in the world in terms of
financial and then hollywood big as at
least as big as the usa i mean
the usa has been pretty stable over the
last decade or two china has been
catching up very quickly with the us box
office
2019 it certainly overtook it but covid
of course has thrown everything you know
out of whack
but the direction of travel is clear
that china is is going to be the biggest
box office in the world the most
valuable industry it produces seven or
800 feature films a year regularly
um those films are now
have been learning from hollywood and
from korea and from hong kong very
self-consciously
in terms of style special effects genres
all the rest of it but also in terms of
release patterns distribution patterns
advertising the whole industry has gone
down that road as you might have noticed
hollywood is not a very adventurous
industry
and that's because it's very concerned
with profit and loss and major budgets
and now the same is true in china too
plus political censorship so it just
becomes much more
safe yeah and well on that i think you
know kevin is such a big market but
there are you know people in the west
don't still don't know about modern
chinese films the fact that um i think
wolf warrior 2 which was a film from
2017 and um what gave the name of wolf
warriors to these very aggressive
diplomats in chinese international stage
this film i was shocked to read was
actually the second highest grossing
international film of all time second
only to star wars um which is amazing
even though
i don't think anyone or any of our
listeners would necessarily have seen i
personally haven't seen it um but it
just makes you wonder there's a massive
kind of divergence between the two
markets there isn't there what is
successful in china is not what is
successful internationally right so that
is the big challenge that the chinese
film industry feels at the moment it
wants to be another hollywood
it wants to be globally successful but a
film like wolf warrior 2
um
gets 99 point something percent of its
box office inside china itself right so
far they've not been making that kind of
export breakthrough
partly it might be because the film is
extremely
jingoistic
you know
full of very racist stereotypes about
africa and also about europeans yeah and
americans and so on
and so those export markets are probably
not going to welcome that film
um
but also uh with this kind of
uh
sense that chinese films are imitating
hollywood you know people feel like well
i can watch the hollywood i can watch
the real thing so the moment they're not
distinctive either there isn't a sense
that
you go there because you're getting
something you're not going to get from
hollywood yeah
and chris before we finish up i just
want to ask you
a question about hollywood and china's
relationship because there's always this
worry that hollywood sanitizes itself
for the chinese market
or that china chinese authorities make
hollywood stand aside so for example
with a remake of mulan a few years ago
um they shot in xinjiang yeah
uh quite a lot even though you know
although at that time to be fair people
were not aware of
what was going on in xinjiang yeah yeah
um and yeah so i guess there's always
this concern that what we in the free
liberal west are consuming in terms of
our soft power in terms of our popular
culture is being influenced and
controlled by uh by people in beijing
that is a very uncomfortable thought how
serious of worry do you think that it
could be um i think that we have to
recognize or distinguish between
hollywood
and american films that are made
on lower budgets for local markets that
address local concerns
and films that are made for a global
market
and those are the sort of transformers
type films and so on and the marvel
comic films and everything else for
those films i think it's true that in
some cases
they can
flop in america but make their money
back in china right
so uh of course ideally they would make
their money everywhere but it does mean
that of course hollywood is very aware
of what we'll play in china or what
won't
and
i think there's been a lot of negative
reaction to that recently and a lot of
publicity and coverage in the us
and as a result the relationship which
had grown up in the teens which was
becoming closer and closer has begun to
unravel
and
i think that chinese investment in
hollywood has been pulled out a lot and
similarly american
filmmakers and american producers
are aware that there's a danger of a
backlash so even though they still want
to get access to that chinese market um
they're not willing to make so many
compromises
at the same time china has not been so
open so in the last few years
hollywood films which had been taking
about 50 percent of the um chinese
market
probably it's down to 30 yeah
so actually chinese films are even more
dominant in their own marketplace yeah
well i saw i saw some stats saying i
think in the last 10 years the highest
grossing films in china were all chinese
with the exception of avengers end game
um i think yes it's been that moving in
that direction more and more and there
was a time when even 10 years ago like
it was the actually the 3d version of
titanic was released and that was the
number one in china in
2012 i think
um
you would see
probably half the films in the top 10
chinese films half of them hollywood
films
now it's more and more chinese films
chinese films yeah why do you think that
is what does that say about the audience
that their tastes are i think the
audience you've got to remember we've
got a whole generation now that's been
brought up
with
very much more
patriotic slash nationalistic education
system
they've been uh told again and again
that the west is their enemy yeah so
perhaps it's not surprising that uh some
of them considerable numbers of them
are not so receptive to hollywood films
at the same time
there's uh another section of the public
that is more open and is more interested
in the outside world
we have to see where things will go it's
hard to know yeah
and chris very finally um even if it's
just for me can you recommend me some
films some new chinese films to watch
maybe from the last 15 years that you
think demonstrate that the film industry
isn't completely
commercialized and stifled
um
even among the commercial films some of
them are more interesting than you might
expect
i would say
the film to go and see at the moment is
hi mom
have you heard of this
so hi mom was the surprise hit last year
it's by a pudgy tv comedian called
jaling she's the director and the star
and it's a mother-daughter relationship
film
it's completely not the sort of
nationalistic
anti-foreign film that we're expecting
these days from china
and instead it's a kind of time travel
film she
feels she's always a disappointment to
her mother and she goes back in time to
just before her she was born before her
mother was married
and
finds herself trying to
set her mother up with a different guy
to marry
in a way because she doesn't want her
mother to have this disappointing
daughter
but in the process of course it all gets
you know reworked and so on but what
interests me about it is that it's it
the period it goes back to
is just after the end of the cultural
revolution the period we were talking
about earlier
when china was opening up to the world
when the reforms were happening when
everything seemed much more optimistic
and when the negativity of the last few
years was not around
so
that was not a film that anyone
anticipated was going to be a mega hit
um they were thinking you know lake
chang jin which you've probably heard of
the korean war film where it's all about
killing americans basically and it's
been a huge hit
but then also this other film which
people didn't think was going to be a
hit has also been a mega hit
so there are other films like that
i think unfortunately in the area of
more art filmmaking um you it's
certainly quite a good idea to go and
see something like kylie blues which is
very
exciting film which goes almost into
somebody's mind yeah um
that's the one
with the incredibly long take yes with
the motorbike cycling around this one
village yes yeah i've seen that one um
that's a very fascinating film
i would compare that i mean the
filmmaker himself
says that his famous favorite filmmaker
or one of his favorite filmmakers is the
russian filmmaker tarkovsky and
tarkovsky also made these very
solipsistic mental sort of films where
you go into your own into the experience
the dream the memory
the trying to convey visually
those kinds of things
in the brezhnev era in the late soviet
era when again you could deal with all
kinds of high art things but you
couldn't touch on any social issues
it seems to me in china at the moment
we've also got that situation where
you've got a kind of high art cinema and
the sense sensors are letting all that
through no problem
so long as it doesn't deal with any
contemporary social issues yeah it's the
contemporary social issues that are much
trickier and they are only allowed if
they're the kinds of social issues that
the government has decided okay we can
address this now this is okay now and
where would people in the west find
these films because a lot of the old
films are on youtube and some of them
have english subtitles some of them
don't i'm sorry to say um but for a lot
of new films i mean i've struggled to
find
i'm i think actually they are showing
maybe not so much in the last year or
two because it covered but before covert
a lot of these films were showing
in major university towns in the uk
in the local odeon actually
because of the local chinese student
population
but they weren't necessarily being
advertised
to a general population in the uk
so
you'd have to sort of know that you were
searching for
contemporary chinese films in release in
the uk
but they were around
and it was surprisingly
possible to see some of these films yeah
brilliant professor chris berry thank
you so much for joining chinese whispers
thank you very much
if you've just come across the podcast
on youtube you can find more episodes
through searching for chinese whispers
wherever you get your podcast from there
is a brilliant backlog of episodes not
on youtube and if you have feedback do
leave a comment below preferably
constructive and subscribe to the
spectator's youtube channel so you never
miss any of our spectator tv shows
thanks for watching
[Music]
you